non so se vi ricordate allora chi mi
segue da tipo ii inizi inizi inizi
quando gesù creò tutti quanti
sa che io ai tempi faceva un sacco trova
in thing si chiamava quella roba
comunque dove disegna vie gli altri
dovevano indovinare cosa vi disegnato no
adesso non c'è più quella roba lì
purtroppo però è uscito scrive l'io è
sempre quei siti questo punto io che non
ho mai capito che cosa che mi significa
dove puoi fare la stessa cosa ovviamente
ci sono inglese tedesco bush ed ecco
cos'è l'italia
bol non sono italiano porcos i play
allora veniamo se indovino cosa fa aiuto
indovinare prima di tutti
ecco come non detto sono entrati dentro
visse messenione incredibile entriamo in
altra pratica play ok io devo indovinare
prima degli altri
alle parole sono questo che è molto
semplice molto figo tra l'altro ok credo
sia in inglese immagino quindi va bene
alla boa bot barca barca come si chiama
se il bot
niente linea pira pyramid cos'è sta roba
è un formaggio dopo trappola per topi e
come si centra propria trappola per topi
in inglese mouse trap mousetrap muse
trap no
mau mau mau set mouse trap muse trap
muse trap porca vacca come io indovinato
nostro scrive mouse trap tre volte
perché c'è scritto che sono italia mouse
la parola era mouse trap veramente mawa
non c'era grazie
senti dinho fa qualcosa sarà tolta l'ho
beccato ultima beccano e la prima non me
l'ha presa ma forse perché ero fuori dal
round camryn vai camerin
quando vuoi e per carità a donald trump
cos'è sta roba qua cos'è cos'è cos'è e
la bandiera del giappone col cerchio
fuori la bandiera del giappone per gli
ubriachi notifica notizie facebook
notifica di facebook noti come si
notifiche in inglese notification
signori quota man anche di non mi ha
battuto
è veramente una notifica l'ha fatta
benissimo dai una cagata raga non potete
non indovinarlo io solo perché non solo
inglese se non l'avrei dominata per
primo li mortacci de dino sei tra di voi
c'è qualcuno che si ama di no sto
scherzando
cioè non dino tudino lui ciotola cup
capoti cup di zuppa zuppa di fitflop
flower power erba erba al green green
bush gesù come hanno fatto indovinarla
cos'è sta roba insalata salad scopini di
cose l'inglese in yen the english
comunque ho fatto un pò schifo
dettagliate però vabbè è finita la
partita va beh dai sono arrivato settimo
sono anche nero con la barba non è vero
non è quello il mio problema è che sono
entrato dopo 15 st che sia arrivato
ultimo stavolta libro prima altrimenti
vi ammazzo tutti compreso dino audino è
uscito scherzava bottiglia bottiglia di
vino cosas tra mickey ha fatto è scemo
cosa mi rappresenta con la roba a
sinistra o sei solo tu zio ma che mouse
già sto tizio spiegami bottle whisky con
la scritta whisky sul serio
sembrava troppo una bottiglia di whisky
che ce l'hai scritta e uno perché c'ha
profumate ma chi è ma neanche un bambino
lo fa così io devo fare
chiusa awards skrillex come faccio a
disegnare il krill l'ex non sto male
aspetta schiena va avere tra tutti
skrillex l'attrice una foto che scrive
chi è che ha fatto strage rover skrillex
come fai di dominare skrillex non ce la
farò mai regala impossibile non woman
woman non è una donna non è una donna di
j
e bellissimo che se skrillex ragazzi non
è difficile
fidatevi dj e indigenti ragazzi questo è
il mio skrillex
esatto dai dichiara facilissima più di
così coloro farvi era difficilissima
lega skrillex rankin indovinabili il
proprio in indovina b le prove allora
impegniamoci per carità difficile
accendino light co demonio talk show tor
ciao no che cosa chi è cosa è stato
brutto
non ho mai visto fare una persona così
male né di mai sono terzo tensione harry
potter come a glasses caccia a cameri
potter madonna che materia ma avete mai
fatto una faccia io faccio schifo a
disegnare per l'amor di dio però madonna
c'è veramente ti sta impegnando e fa
così schifo
luigi di maio come hanno fatto non
indovinarlo quei due mi chiedo sveglio
nero cos'è cos'è una pianta una palma al
no cos'è sta roba brutta storia è una
tipa cos'è allora che non sto capendo a
braccio a braccio come lo fa come ha
fatto indoviniamo quello ma cosa mi
rappresenta
sto male la nostra
katy perry katy perry ma questo è scemo
io devo disegnare cosa devo disegnare
cosa madonna si disegnate da cani raga
quello come ha fatto indovinare vanno
fatte ma come possiamo farlo si ma cos'è
ma dai
cosa mi rappresenta sto schifo scelgo io
player hospital crossbow black player
giocatore giocatore lo facciamo così al
televisore o dai e player è facilissimo
lui se in di colui cos'è console lui lui
porca vacca gamer è più o meno più o
meno 12 nov la cosa nel flash player dai
è facilissimo e voi youtuber player
natura è facilissimo ma porca vacca era
facilissima ma sede scemi quindi così
non lo so 3
l'hotel nominato io per primo fortezza
cosa c'entrano gli alberi una fortezza
non c'entrano niente la fortezza un
altra roba da quando partono già subito
mi può benissimo
cioè fidati godzilla
oddio oddio al cursore del mouse muse
cursor lavori fetta tour eiffel e non è
la tour eiffel torre eiffel e lo scritto
lo script
rehn inglese li mortacci degli inglesi
porca vacca torre i pesi chi vettore
ferro nei file power e non è che noi
veniamo ai vostri grattacieli che
chiamiamo google da 109 sky sky
skyscraper in english perché siamo si
chiama skyscraper no quindi non un
grattacielo quindi se tu vieni a parigi
ma che dici eiffel tower mai a roma e
dicevo popoli se un po colosseo a
riportarci ledoux sorella si inglesi ma
ledeva beh dai rega non vale però non
nuovo che si sta rompendo e un rene ore
nei kit nail sembra un rene e art after
nuclear war neige brain è un cervello e
insetti non mi chiamate perché non vanno
nel momento di un godermi la vittoria
tu sorella un genio un genio un fenomeno
einstein da un cervello mi è venuto
segua vj pa vigenza vj che einstein pa
vj mouse pa vj maledizione che einstein
potra varca una vittoria schiacciante
con do tra l'altro chi è prima di
mortacci ming wong falla
sì ma secondo te se fai prima fai
primaria il principi e poi la caduta non
fai bene la caduta e poi fai precipitano
fa il contrario è stato l'agente
indovina sono io scemo pro 9 con beat
sui side anna bagger d'esposito
d'esposito perché der picnic bull
bullard c'è un pullman che sono lì
facciamo così da guerra aspetta la red
bull svetta non mi dico come è fatta la
red bull tipo così come si riempie dai
facilissimo indovinate adesso degli
scemi forte
red bull ok senza red visto che sono
quattro lettere di uno die sasà bull red
ma tu sei scemo come ha fatto a
indovinarlo ragazzi io veramente va must
massimi di basta basta basta
come dice basta basta in inglese basta
destino del si no
ragazzi ho dato prova della mia
auspicabile maestria solida spiegabile
spero che siate contenti è bellissimo
giuro ne farò sicuramente un altro
episodio ma altri anche venti forse
anche in live non saprebbe bellissimo
qui ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto giotto
era mia parente anche picasso però
quelli sono altri discorsi blow dirò più
avanti fare un video dedicato
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzino
senso che ci piaceva tanto mi piace
anche ai soci qui la data di iscrizione
sono sono così siete e noi ci siamo a un
prossimo disegno o quadro o arte moderna
che ne so da ragazzi
[Musica]